bonjour pierre laurin bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin dans la matinale berthet france
premier face à face entre joe biden et
vladimir zelensky ils se rencontrent
pour la première fois en personne est
collé au courant va mieux passé que sous
donald trump
c'est très difficile à dire parce que
même si effectivement les relations
doivent être meilleur
que sous donald trump le les états unis
en ce moment son nom une chanson ou dans
une phase de repli c'est à dire que il
leur est très difficile de s'engager
de la manière dont l'ukraine le voudrait
dans ce dossier il est fort probable que
à part des annonces comme le l'accord
conclu hier qu'il ne changerait pas
grand chose aux fondus du problème en
particulier dans le domaine basse il n'y
aura pas de véritable percée
indiscutablement les états unis vont
soutenir verbalement l'ukraine mais
les résultats concrets ne seront pas à
la hauteur des espérances de pièces en
tout cas il ya eu déjà une première
déclaration on l'a vu du ministre de la
défense américain contre moscou contre
évidemment
la présence en crimée
en crimée plus pratiquement pas c'est ce
que les américains n'arrêtent pas de
répéter même à l'époque de tram ça ça ne
change pas c'est toujours la même phrase
urologie 1
les etats-unis comme l'europe
occidentale ne vous connaissent pas le
rattachement de la tri mais à l'abc et
donc cours pour ces pays en question
c'est la russie qui est l'agresseur est
donc là rien ne change ils auraient été
des paiements que le ministre la défense
américain de
l'ojd obstine ne disent pas ne répond
déjà c'est une rencontre qui intervient
également dans un contexte de tension de
regain de tension dans le donbass
hossa le regain de tension
enfin le sert à toutes les sauces il ya
toujours des incidents mais chaque fois
qu'il y ait une rencontre internationale
qui implique les occidentaux et
l'ukraine les ukrainiens met en avant
des incidents qui se sont produits et
c'est une recrudescence alors qu'en fait
il ne se passe sensiblement rien de
nouveau sur le front c'est toujours des
escarmouches c'est toujours des attaques
qui sont contre elle ou pas contre est
de part et d'autre avec des morts et et
puis bon maintenant c'est un conflit de
basse intensité il ne faut pas penser
que le dôme bas c'est réellement à feu
et à sang aujourd'hui ça pourrait le
devenir d'ici quelques temps ça l'a été
à une certaine époque maintenant à part
ces escarmouches il ne se passe pas
grand chose on sait que l'ukraine
attendent beaucoup des américains il y a
le soutien un militaire évidemment il y
à aussi l'entrée dans l'otan avec ce qui
se passe en afghanistan les certains
médias ukrainiens commença à être un peu
sceptique sur l'efficacité de cette
organisation qu'on pensez vous alors je
crois que les médias ukrainiens
constate simplement ce que tout le monde
voit depuis longtemps je vous rappelle
que le président emmanuel macron avait
dit que l'otan était un état de mort
cérébrale
c'est
hélas pour pour les élites otanienne
c'est un fait que tout le monde constate
les ukrainiens comme les autres
maintenant ce qui est important et je
crois que pour l'ukraine c'est assez
c'est vital c'est que
l'adhésion à l'otan qui est espérée par
beaucoup en ukraine ne peut pas se faire
et ne se fera pas dans un futur
proche ou un peu plus éloigné il
faudrait qu'il y ait beaucoup de choses
qui changent et les américains même si
ils ne le disent pas parce que ils
veulent recevra zelensky mais bayonne va
va en parler à mes d'une manière très
franche le fruit pardon très feutré
ce que wade n va dit attention vous
devez lutter contre la corruption une
corruption qui est endémique et massive
et ça fait 2 ans monsieur zelensky que
vous êtes au pouvoir et rien n'a été
fait mais le président bailly donne doit
être très prudent sur le dossier de la
corruption parce qu'il ya toujours une
affaire en cours qui implique à une à
une une société qui s'appelle but risma
holding dans laquelle son fils un top
hayden était impliqué et byden lorsqu'il
était vice-président était chargé des
affaires de l'ukraine et il se comporte
et non pas comme un partenaire mais
plutôt comme une sorte de proconsul
américain qui réglait les choses en
particulier il a fait démettre de ses
fonctions un procureur général qui
justement essayer de lutter contre la
corruption c'est très curieux cette
histoire parce que personne n'en a parlé
on parle de donald trump qui a essayé de
faire chanter zielinski mais alors que
là il y à une ingérence avérée d'un vice
président des etats-unis qui a reconnu
lui même devant les caméras qu'il avait
fait virer c'est son terme le procureur
général ça ça reste
[Musique]
sous le tapis on n'en parle pas mais ça
risque à tout moment d'éclater d'autant
plus que aujourd'hui le président bailly
donne n'est pas auréolé de cette image
de héros en titre 1 piste qu'il fallait
porter à toute force à la présidence
aujourd'hui c'est un président on le
voit affaibli qui essaye de justifier le
retrait manquée d'afghanistan et qui ne
peut aujourd'hui que se raccrocher aux
branches très copia lorrain il nous
reste peu de temps la question du du
gazoduc north stream ii également sera
sur la table alors que les états unis
l'ont approuvé
non il ne soit il ne sera pas sous la
table ce qui ce qui sera sur la table
c'est simplement le fait que les
américains comme les allemands et comme
tous les européens vont insister pour
que le transit du gaz par l'ukraine
reste constant qui ne soit pas diminuée
elle simplement parce que on a doublé
les capacités de le lieu du nord stream
puisqu'il y avait déjà il ya déjà depuis
longtemps une branche qui est en
fonctionnement et le north stream 2
vient doubler cette branche mais si
les russes d'ailleurs ont assuré depuis
très longtemps qu'il ne toucherait pas
au débit du des gaz des gazoducs qui
traversent l'ukraine que ce serait
constant qu'il n'y aurait pas de
problème est là il est une négociation
sur le prix du transit du gaz enfin les
choses sont à peu près
dans le sur les rails mais effectivement
les américains ont insisté sur le fait
que les russes doivent respecter
l'accord de transit de gaz avec
l'ukraine donc merci beaucoup pierre
laurin pour votre analyse ce matin en
direct dans la matinale d'arreter france